[Music]
now I'm curious birthday last week
am i correct yeah how'd you celebrate my
wife and I went out to dinner went out
to a nice dinner in New York City and
can I just say for the record Conan that
this whole foodie obsession that's going
on in America's big cities it just
drives me crazy it makes me sick all
right well let's be specific you're
talking about people that really
fetishize special kind of hipsters do it
these stirs do it urban i'ts do it but
they wait like months in advance at
reservations at the right little diner
oh you've got to go to Ming mom's
restaurant cuz the chef is half
Ethiopian and half Finnish and he makes
meatballs out of goat makes and yoky
with Meyer lemon and squid it's amazing
and they can't eat anything else I mean
have we not learned a lesson from
history Conan what was the last great
civilization that gorged and vomited
over and over again but yeah Andy the
Romans the Romans
I was and what happened to them Midwest
anyone from Wisconsin yeah no we're
talking about that whole civilization
collapse they were so busy eating and
vomiting and the Vandals came and tore
down the gates and they're all dead now
and I mean it's we've been he's dead
anyway it was 2,000 years
another all day are you quibble think
about it think about it so what you're
saying is you think it's bad for us as a
society to be fetishizing these it's
just wrong okay well what did you eat on
your birthday oh my god it was so
delicious we went to this place called
batard I had to octopus pastrami it was
you know I was just like let Rome burn I
am delicious octopus pastrami it's it's
exquisite it paired with the white wine
oh of course of course all right
you